last night lizzo made history
[Music]
[Applause]
we just made history tonight
[Applause]
and making history freaking cool history
is freaking cool you guys
lizzo twerked and played James Madison's
Crystal Flute from the 1800s it was
historic
so was the Hindenburg so was the
conquest of Constantinople not all
historic events are good or praiseworthy
I actually kind of like lizzo I do I
know I know it's not popular on the
right I like lizzo I think her music is
somewhat catchy The Outfits uh not not
my thing but the music's somewhat catchy
and as far as modern musical artists go
I stand her okay she is a surprisingly
skilled flautist all of that is true
but lizzo should not have been given
special permission to play James
Madison's flute for two reasons
first one because lizzo is not dignified
she could be dignified if she wanted to
be but she is not and it is degrading to
our nation for a lady simultaneously to
twerk and jiggle and degrade herself and
to play an historical artifact that
belonged to the father of the
Constitution Second lizzo should not
have been given special permission to
play the flute because the entire
performance was intended as an act of
hostility toward James Madison toward
the founding fathers and toward the
historical American Nation
I don't think lizzo intended it as a
hostile act but the libs generally did
the New York Times reported quote it was
a symbolic moment as lizzo a hugely
popular black singer rapper and
songwriter played a Priceless instrument
that once belonged to a Founder whose
Virginia Plantation was built by
enslaved black workers and the flute had
been lent to her by Carla D Hayden the
first African-American and woman to lead
the Library of Congress
in other words
the performance was not to be an honor
it was set up and seen as an act of
revenge against a no-good long dead
racist and the the nation that he
represents
it was set up and reported as an act of
Liberation by a self-described victim of
Oppression I don't know what uh music
video for good means but I do know what
your vote means and that's a lot
your vote means everything to me it
means everything to making a change in
this country
[Music]
so remember when you're voting for your
favorite artist vote to change some of
these laws that are oppressing us
now lizzo of course is not oppressed and
our founding fathers were not oppressors
the country they established is not evil
and both the men and the country deserve
better than to be mocked with a twerk
the climate change activist Izzy cook
has just accidentally on television
exemplified
the the hypocrisy at the heart not just
of the environmentalist movement on the
left but of the left broadly
so we would have to apply to have like
approved events to be able to fly for
well that's one thing that you could
look at doing
am I allowed to go to Fiji is that
necessary
in the current climate crisis I don't
think that that's necessary when was the
last time you were on a plane
um
I'm not sure maybe
a few months ago to be on where'd you go
Fiji
Izzy
is he
don't you care about the climate Izzy of
course I care about the climate not
enough you went
you went to jail is he come on maze are
you so very serious
are you serious is he
this is of course the way to respond to
all of the alarmism all of the hysterics
about how the world is going to end you
just sort of laugh at it because you can
say Obviously the libs don't believe
this if the libs believed that getting
on an airplane was going to destroy the
entire world then they wouldn't do it or
they're just Stone Cold Psychopaths but
they do it they do it all the time and
so we don't need to take it seriously
the whole Davos crew that tells us that
we need to go eat bugs and we have to
stop living and we have to live in tiny
little pods and we can't have meat and
we can't go work and we can't travel and
we can't drive a car and we can't do
anything anymore that same crew
they all fly private jets halfway across
the world to go on a fun ski vacation
with a bunch of other Elites around the
world okay and so we don't need to take
that seriously
as a as a matter of life or death for
the world we do have to take it
seriously as a political movement
but we need to start examining the real
motivations here why why is it that
these very wealthy powerful influential
people want to Peddle the climate change
stuff is it because they really believe
in it most of the time I don't think it
is
most of the time I think it's a power
play it gives them more power the
technocracy more power the international
institutions more power the handful of
corporations that are wielding a lot of
influence on those other institutions it
gives them a lot more power think about
it with covid why did the most powerful
interests in the country push to shut
down the country during covid is it
really because they thought that
everyone was going to die if we were
closer than six feet away from one
another and we took that little hanky
off our face no of course not because
all of those people regularly would take
the little hanky off and they would
violate all the rules and Gavin Newsom
would show up to the French Laundry and
these CEOs and the oligarchs and the
Masters of the Universe would routinely
regularly violate their own coveted
rules
when they thought that the cameras
weren't rolling
so what is it is it just is it just
hypocrisy or is it just a failure to
live up to their standards no I think
there's a little bit more than that
think about covid covid represented the
largest transfer of wealth from the
lower classes to the upper classes ever
in the entire history of the world very
often there are there are Financial
motivations and power politics
motivations I was just in the Bronx
yesterday I was in this old wonderful
neighborhood I've been going to and
since I was a very little kid we would
do our grocery shopping there and I
don't know maybe being around those
Italian Americans it gives you a little
bit more of an edge and you you know it
gives you a little bit of that sense of
hold on what's really at play here is
someone really trying to pull one over
on us and so I think you got to just
laugh at it okay you got to laugh at it
then you got to examine where the real
motivations are
and then you you've got to be much
better armed to to fight back against
them now is the time for the member
block okay the rest of the show is
continuing now we moved woke Wednesday
to Thursday because I was on the road so
we've got a video from The New York
Times I have not seen it yet I have been
told this even by New York Times
standards is really really
horrific so I can't wait that'll be
great if you don't want to miss it if
you're not a member head on over click
the link in the description and join us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]